Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Connors again. This video is going to be on the respiratory cancers.
Cancer's in the lung, the bronchial tubes, the bronchial, bronchiaid, the
larynx, the trachea,
the lung cavity, the upper respiratory system.
It's a very scary cancer when you're diagnosed because one of the scariest things to happen is that you can't breathe.
We have family members with asthma. I know what that's like.
I know it's it's it's easy when you would anybody hears a diagnosed of cancer to be very frightened and to make decisions out of that fear and and though you want to
make a decision fairly soon in your treatment.
Don't think that you should ever make a decision based upon fear. So just be careful that slow down
take your time digest the information when you hear that you have cancer to help you make the best decision possible so that you don't have regrets.
Don't the way.
There's a lot of cancers that are tied into this. Some have better results through standards of care than others.
All of them will have better results if you do add alternative care to it as well.
Now some people just choose to do alternative all together and we're here to help them with that, but certainly if you're going to do standards of care, at least consider doing some dietary change, doing some
food restrictions, some fasting and definitely some specific nutrition, and we are very big on the rife technology that's going to
in my opinion, be a huge piece that's going to add years to your life and quality to your years as well.
So don't think that it's exclusive. Don't think that that's the biggest thing that we hear from people. I didn't know what to choose.
So I chose to go with my oncologist. Well, it doesn't mean that you can't choose to do alternative care as well.
We'll guide you through that pathway. So you should be doing natural things if you're going to do standards of care and you certainly better be doing some natural things if you choose not to do
standards of care. You want to be treating this as a serious disease, but you also don't want to think that you have to be exclusive one way or the other.
When you're adding natural things, it is very confusing. I understand that it feels like sometimes you're drinking from a fire hose.
All your friends and neighbors come out of the woodwork telling you to take this or that because their friends brother took this and that worked for them.
Well, we want to test you specifically to find out what's going to work for you.
So our patients, when they come to us, we do a cheek swab, we do a full genetic workup. In order to test them, what diet is going to be best for them?
We certainly don't want to be eating things that are fueling your cancer. So we'll test for that to get that specific.
Just by the way, we don't put people on these very difficult diets like we're going to put you on a full keto diet and get you into ketosis.
We don't do that typically. We're going to just take out this specific foods that we think are fueling your cancer.
It's a much easier way to live and doesn't steal all the joy out of your life. We also want to test you what specific nutrients,
nutraceuticals are going to be the best quote unquote cancer killers for you.
And then we use the right and I think that's a key component for everybody's cancer, but we need to have it program specifically for you.
So we test for frequencies. So that's our piece we're adding, you know, specificity to your unique protocol.
So you can rest assured you're doing everything that you possibly can to get the best outcome because ultimately that's really what we want for you.
We want the best outcome and for you to add years to your life and quality to your year. So the better what you choose, please use our website.
Download the information. Download my books and know that we'll be praying for you. No matter what.